[Музика]
ну всім, настав час для уроків англійської,
мене звати Хана, і наш останній
урок я запрошую вас подорожувати
найкращою країною світу, яку країна
буде любити та цінувати, бо вона наша,
давайте подорожувати Україною нехай  ми запрошуємо
вас на побачення з країною, яка буде
любити та цінувати,
дозвольте нам повезти вас туди, де ви ніколи не
були
ми історична спадщина, увійшли вина
з чистою красою та спокоєм,
де панує природа, а людина
давайте вийдемо та подивимося навколо
, подивимося  Україна тож давайте зосередимося на деяких
словах із відео країна, де
історична спадщина переплітається з
чистою красою та спокоєм, коли панує природа
і велика людина, зверніть увагу на ці
слова
історична спадщина історична спадщина
– це багатство бадук історична
спадщина скажемо разом історична
спадщина ще раз  історична
спадщина малюк інше слово переплітається
воно ось-ось переплететься
страшно переплететься сьогодні сер
переплітайте повторіть переплітайте малюк
наступне ви  re beauty
trista Krassin чиста краса малюк і
вся фраза історична спадщина
переплітається з чистою красою і спокоєм,
але природа править привада через
приватну природу править людина створює людину
створює цілу фразу країна,
де править природа, а людина велика
отримує подивіться на ці питання  подумайте про
власні відповіді, що є
найважливішим в Україні, що змушує
вас пишатися країною, і чому
Regino про сім
чудес України зосереджується на першому питанні,
спочатку отримайте зараз, давайте зосередимось на другому
питанні, є сім чудес
України  ви чули про них ми
дізнаємося сказав, що ви збираєтеся читати
текст і це питання, на які потрібно
відповісти питання номер один що це
за сім чудес україни що
вони і як їх відбирали прочитайте та
знайдіть відповіді правильно як  якщо вони
вибрали, то опитування було проведено правильно
і ось результати опитування
добре на сьогоднішньому уроці ми
прочитаємо про п'ять із них  і виконайте
завдання на відповідність, щоб це було вашим завданням для
читання, щоб читати та відповідати текстам і
висловлюванням, тому це будуть завдання на відповідність,
як-от Ins Anna читання для та читання
шість, які швидко пройдіть через ці
етапи, як виконувати ці типи завдань, тому
спочатку прочитайте  висловлювання та
підкресліть ключові слова, думайте про синоніми
як протилежності, які ви можете побачити в текстах
крок номер два прочитайте перший
уривок перший текст
тітка Бенна сформулюйте
його головну ідею та знайдіть
твердження або це можуть бути підзаголовки,
які відповідають цьому тексту  це і
продовжуйте процедуру, читайте текст один
за одним і щоразу
підкреслюйте ключові слова та знайдіть
відповідність, на самому останньому етапі зосередьтеся
на непарних висловлюваннях і двічі перевірте,
чи вони дійсно дивні, що
ми маємо зробити спочатку
правильно, прочитати  твердження та
визначте ключові слова, наприклад у першому
вислові, які ключові слова природа
та малі архітектурні форми, які малі
архітектурні форми, як ви знаєте, можуть
це вежа, замок діти L менше,
може бути фонтан чи щось подібне
, добре, так що зробіть решту на власній
пшениці та знайдіть ключові слова
готуйтеся до читання першого тесту
Софійський собор вул.  Софійський
собор є однією з головних
пам'яток архітектурного та
монументального мистецтва початку 11 століття,
він зберігає чудову старовинну
архітектуру та найповніший
у світі матеріал регіональної мозаїки
та фресок, про що йдеться у цьому уривку.
знайдіть відповідний текст готово
перейдемо до другого тексту
громади
паєрський давнє місто громад
Подільський відомий своєю фортецею,
органічною сумішшю культур різних
народів та яскравим фестивальним життям
повітряної кулі в
каньйоні річки Смотрич  щороку приваблюють тисячі туристів,
подумайте про ключові слова
висловлювання виберіть одне 15
національний парк в Оуен-
Софії Парк є одним із всесвітньо відомих
садових парків, створених мистецтвом,
є багато мальовничих місць, включаючи
водоспади, фонтани,
ставки та кам'яний сад, який
пропонує парк  мальовничий краєвид і
багато зелені, щоб відвідувачі могли насолоджуватися
природою  Кращі екскурсії на гондольних
катерах і праворуч уздовж
підземної річки також у
розпорядженні відвідувачів подумайте про ключові слова заяву
фортеця Хоутон фортеця Хотенд –
агресивний фортифікаційний комплекс, розташований
на річках Деніз, праворуч за
будівництво фортеці було
розпочато о 30:25 для  оборонних
цілей і він бачив багато слів
битви та облоги можна побачити
стіни фортеці в багатьох історичних
пригодницьких фільмах і останній текст
це про острів Хорта острів кордетта
найбільший острів на
Дніпрі національний природний заповідник та
історичний комплекс  сьогодні гості цієї
легенди замінили можуть побачити виступи верхової їзди
та постійні битви на
мечах
це правильне місце відчути дух
хороброї концепції, насолоджуючись дивовижними
краєвидами негритянської річки, тому ми прочитали п'ять текстів і
маємо шість варіантів, один з яких дивний
тепер давайте подивимося на тексти, і у
вас буде ще один шанс швидко
перевірити, чи збігаєтеся ви  правильно це
давайте перевіримо разом перший текст був
про Софійський собор, який
за варіантами йому підходить, тому ми читаємо про
архітектуру старовинну архітектуру так
і найгірший неоспіваний куля оригінальних
мозаїк і фресок звучить як
найдавніші шедеври українського мистецтва
та архітектури саме так  частини
згадуються архітектура та мистецтво отримати текст
будь що про communites pajersky
і йдеться про діяльність на повітряній кулі.
Правильно звучить, як ви можете літати
над історичними об'єктами, вдаривши наступну
Софію Капур, які рядки в тексті
допомогли вам визначити правильне
твердження, безперечно, це  про природу
в її найкращих проявах і фонтани кам'яні садові
ставки без різниці між Лос-Анджелесом
і ставком так, ставки створені людиною, тому
всі ці ідеї можуть допомогти нам
знайти варіант, яким можна помилуватися природою та
малими архітектурними формами, вони гарні
сказати  номер один це про п'яту машину
праворуч, наступний текст був про фортецю Хотон,
а рядок тут був про
рекламу  переглядати історичні фільми
тут, ви можете розпізнати місця, які бачили
у фільмах, праворуч, а останнє
про те, що це за острів, що ви
можете там робити - залишилося лише два варіанти
, це варіант номер два та варіант
номер шість, ви можете або дізнатися
історичні  факти про українських
захисників захисники його шия добре
або брати участь у військових боях у
тексті ми можемо знайти рядки про
історичні конфлікти правильно і ви можете
подивитися концептуальні бої на мечах, щоб ви
могли щось дізнатися про українських
захисників це означає, що твердження два
матчі  текст ІІ і варіант на шанс
шість, тому що ми не можемо знайти
в тексті жодної інформації про активну
участь у військових боях, а тепер
зупинимося на словах з цього тексту
зверніть увагу на цей один ансамбль
ансамбль і зразок ансамблю повторіть це
слово ансамбль  отримати скажімо фразу
з цими словами світовий ансамбль
оригінальної мозаїки та фресок ансамбль
театральний ансамбль отримати інше слово
long-s  tanding давнє щось
з довгою історією, що існує
тривалий час довговічне
в нашому випадку це давнє місто
скажімо сказати фразу з цим словом
давнє місто отримати
наступне працює в тексті про  FIFA
мальовничий мальовничий ще раз
мальовничий Малоун eg right picture
мальовничі мальовничі мальовничі
краєвиди
можливо це словосполучення мальовничі пейзажі
отримати мою любов Ніцше мальовничий отримати
добре і ще одне слово з тексту
кількість квартетів острів
це слово мечі мечі як меч багато
патронів hobli a sword W  мовчить тут
слово повторити слово добрі битви
на мечах битва на мечах
добре так ще раз як це сказати
англійською ліловий Ніцше мальовничий комплект
Мілан Нова Зеландія вал мальовничі
краєвиди гарно як сказати ансамбль
ансамбль гарний відповідність Аббас хабла сорт
отримати закручений гарний дотик до Maya Behati
історія дурман хто новий це
давній давній отримати скажімо
давайте назвемо ці дива  rs
перший прийшов блоки Подільська фортеця комплект що
ви про це
дуже швидко згадаєте добре
ще один чи можете ви впізнати Софійський
парк малюка що там робити, щоб насолоджуватися
природою тут посередині це
Софійський собор що ви знаєте про
його історія коли він був побудований
добре дитина 11 століття дуже добре
це
острів Хорта дитина що ви знаєте про це
ви можете відчути дух так, козаків
там добре і останній
фортеця Haughton ми можемо побачити її стіни в багатьох
фільми отримати зараз подумайте і скажіть, які з
цих місць ви вже відвідали,
чи рекомендуєте ви їх і що ви
рекомендуєте там робити, і які ви
хотіли б відвідати, і навіщо візьміть свій
телефон диктофон і підготуйтеся говорити
і записувати тут розмову, щоб де ви"  я
був, чи порадите ви там зробити
і які з них ви б хотіли відвідати
і чому одна хвилина виступу вперед
[Музика]
готово картинка давайте подивимось, а не
фрагмент відео про Україну  Дивіться та вловлюйте
ці слова, ваше завдання полягатиме в тому, щоб
записати прикметники, які вживаються з цими
іменниками, давайте пробіжимося по іменникам
краєвиди поле Луги хвилювання любов
енергія та краса отримати запишіть
числа від 1 до 7 і будьте готові
вловити прикметники, які вживаються з  ці
іменники
[Музика]
на побаченні
[Музика],
поки країна настільки прекрасна, що
ви затамуєте дух,
дозвольте нам підняти вас у небо і показати
вам гроші, чарівні пейзажі
з цієї висоти
дозволять нам зачарувати вас краєвидами,
створеними обома  природа і людина
[Музика
] у золотисто-жовтому полі
[Музика]
або глибоке синє море, що
біжить, як божевільне, запашними
луками
[Оплески]
або ходити босоніж по твердому піску,
їздить чи
літає на човні чи просто стоячи й
озираючись навколо,
ви відчуєте, що  ми відчуваємо
дитяче хвилювання юнацька любов
[Музика]
яскрава енергія та найвища краса, коли
ти озирнешся, ти побачиш усе, ти
побачиш, Україна зроблена давайте перевіримо скажімо
пейзажі неймовірний пейзаж  ес
скажемо разом неймовірні краєвиди
ще раз
неймовірні пейзажі добре про
поле золотисто-жовте поле золотисто-
жовте поле гарне луги запашний
ароматний солодкий ароматний хвилювання
дитяче хвилювання
дитяче хвилювання але любов
Beauty supreme beauty supreme beauty kit
перевірте свою пам'ять зараз, які луги
кажуть ароматний гарний Beauty supreme beauty
Farragut хвилювання дитяче хвилювання
шум Я заповнив золотисто-жовте поле
добре й енергія яскрава енергія супер сер
час говорити та грати скажи зверни увагу
на підказки  завдання полягає в тому, щоб скласти
запитання, використовуючи підказки, і дати на них відповіді,
наприклад, яке питання
ми повинні скласти за допомогою цієї підказки в
столиці України, питання полягає в тому, яка
столиця України, отримати відповідь і
додати інформацію, що ви знаєте про
це місто, яке  ми будемо грати, використовуючи
лише три готові запитання k  це ах,
це перше запитання сказав, що
саме питання, як столиця
України назвала його та надала
інформацію про місто готово
перейдемо до питання номер два там було
сказано місце, де ви народилися, як поставити
це питання де де  чи ти народився
дитиною, назвав це місце так і надайте
інформацію про нього, наприклад, я
народився в невеликому містечку в регіоні ідей
і продовжуйте розповідати про деякі факти про це,
ваша черга
зроблено добре, і
це питання про те, щоб
встигнути  перевірте свої знання з уроків історії,
тому що давайте разом поставимо запитання,
які найважливіші
історичні події, тому запам’ятайте їх і
скажіть принаймні три з них,
щоб ви могли грати в цю гру, відповідаючи на
запитання самостійно, і для нас
настав час підбити підсумки  сказав останню хвилину
не лише уроку, а й
усю частину англійської мови в школі, і
давайте прочитаємо це побажання разом,
безпечної подорожі, життя – це подорож, не
ув’язнюйте себе в  rot
звільнись і подорожуй, дивуйся, ніби ти заблукав,
це єдиний спосіб відкрити себе,
і куди б ти не пішов, іди всім своїм
серцем,
я бажаю втрат і попрощаюсь з тобою
[Музика]